Yeah.
What's your take on universal income?
Is it a fast track to new communism,
capitalism killer or a possible
way out of starvation for humanity?
Thank you.
Well,
I don't think it addresses the
fundamental problem and I think it's a,
I think it's a mirror of the
rights responsibility problem.
No,
you might say,
well everyone has a right to the
basics of life at first of all,
that's a debatable proposition because
the question is who's going
to provide those necessities?
And the answer shouldn't be
someone else under compulsion.
So
because each right comes at the expense
of someone else's responsibility.
And so you don't want to multiply rights
beyond minimum necessity because you
also multiply diverse
responsibilities beyond tolerance.
But more importantly than
that I would say is that
let's make it more concrete.
So let's imagine that as the
technological revolution progresses,
more and more people will be in danger
of being replaced by intelligent
machines.
Now we don't know if that's true
because it hasn't happened yet.
Right.
And everyone has been predicting that
that was going to happen since like 1960
and it hasn't happened.
And so there may be an infinite amount
of work and we're never going to run out
of work.
I suspect that's probably the case.
But let's assume that people do get
dispossessed as technology's transform.
And then we have the problem
of the development of people
for who have no viable
means of making a living.
And the question might be,
well,
what's the fundamental problem there?
And one answer is,
well,
they don't have any money,
but I actually don't think that
that is the fundamental problem.
Um,
I've had many people in my
clinical practice who were
unemployed and had money.
Now they didn't have a lot of money,
but they had enough money and enough
money to keep privation at bay,
let's say.
And enough money to,
well,
that was the rub.
Enough money to get themselves
into plenty of trouble.
And so one of my clients,
for example,
was a,
I liked him quite a lot.
And he had,
he was,
he had worked in a hospital
and he'd been hurt.
And,
and then he got onto painkillers
because he'd been hurt.
And then he got addicted to painkillers
and then he got addicted to cocaine and
his life took a bad nosedive and he is
actually pretty good unless he had money.
But as soon as he had a check,
it was,
he was gone.
He was in a ditch,
he was in a bar,
he spent all his money and
he was face down in a ditch.
And that's where he woke up the next day.
And the reason I'm telling you that
story is because it wasn't that he didn't
have money,
that wasn't the problem.
Really.
The problem was that he
didn't have a purpose.
He didn't have a place anymore.
He got thrown out of the structure
that would have enabled him to find
productive meaning,
you know,
when you might've said,
well,
he should have been able to
conjure that up on his own.
And perhaps that's the case.
Although he wasn't the world's
most sophisticated person,
you know,
and people very substantially
in their sophistication and it,
and he didn't have a good family.
He didn't have a support
network around him.
He was kind of a lost character in many,
many ways.
And so it was easy for him
to fall out of the world,
which is what he did.
And providing him with money was not
going to fix that and say what is going to
fix that?
Well that's a good question.
I mean,
we have a program,
some of you people might
be interested in it.
It's called,
it's part of a suite of online writing
programs called the self authoring suite.
It's out self authoring dot calm and
one of the programs is called future
authoring.
And we've experimented with this program
in an attempt to address this problem.
Okay.
So I mentioned to you tonight the idea
that we live out a story and we need a
purpose to live out that story properly.
And what that implies is
that you need a purpose.
You need a point,
you need a name,
you need to precise saying you
need an aim that's of sufficient
nobility.
I can't think of any other word,
sufficient,
no ability to justify your miserable
existence even to yourself.
And you need to develop that aim.
And so we built this program.
I started working on it about 15 years
ago when I was giving my students
exercises to do at university.
And one of the exercises I had them do
was that they had to pick a small problem
maybe in their family or
with their room and fix it,
not try to fix it,
you know,
but actually pick a problem that
was small that they could fix,
clean up the cigarette butts in the yard,
outside the residents.
Um,
clean the room.
We had one kid whose mother
had died in the family,
got kind of fragmented and he decided
that he was going to take over the
maternal duties in the household and the
kids were supposed to write about what
happened when they tried to put this
into practice because doing things like
that is way more difficult
than anybody ever realizes.
And so he tried to become mother and
the family needed a mother and he,
he encountered all sorts
of terrible resistance,
which is completely unsurprising.
I mean,
first of all,
people in his family were annoyed that
he would dare to try to take their dead
mother's place.
You know,
even though he was trying to do
it for the best of reasons and we,
I played with that for a couple of
years and that was very interesting.
And then I realized that I was teaching
students all these stories about
purpose,
but nobody had ever had them write a
story about their purpose essentially.
So I thought,
well,
isn't that interesting here are these,
these,
these kids,
they've been in university,
they've been in school for 15 years
and no one has ever
sat them down and said,
well what sort of character
do you want to develop?
Who should you be and why don't
you write that out and justify it,
you know,
six pages,
something like that with the same amount
of care and attention that you might
spend or even more on an essay about
the war of 1812 or something like that.
Think well,
and the more I thought about that,
the more
okay.
Flabbergasted I would say
I became because I thought,
well,
what the heck?
How is it possible that we could set
up an education system and run people
through it for 15 years
and never have them forced,
so to speak,
to figure out who they want it to be and
to justify it in an articulate manner.
And so I built this program with my
colleagues to help people do that.
And I used it my classes first.
And so I thought,
okay,
well here's the game and this is like
rural to treat yourself like you're
someone responsible for helping.
And that doesn't mean be good to yourself.
It doesn't mean me be nice to yourself.
It doesn't mean give yourself an easy
life that isn't actually what you do to
people.
If you care for them,
you actually present them with
something like an optimal challenge.
That's what you do with kids.
If you love them as you present them
with an optimal challenge so they can
develop and grow.
So that's what you should do for yourself
if you're taking care of yourself.
So I just thought,
okay,
well here's the game.
First of all,
assume that you're worth taking a
care that you're worth taking care of.
And that it's your
responsibility to do so.
Even if you don't like yourself very much.
And lots of people don't and they have
their reasons because everybody is very
aware of their own flaws,
right?
Unless you're narcissistic,
you're more aware of your own
flaws then of anyone else's flaws.
And maybe you're not very happy with
yourself and you don't think that you
deserve to have an okay life.
And so you punish yourself and you set
yourself up for failure and all and all
of that,
and that happens all the time.
Or you just don't aim or you don't have
any goals or you know you're guilty and
resentful and feel that
you should be punished.
So you have to abandon all that.
Treat yourself like you're someone
you're responsible for helping,
responsible for helping.
Imagine yourself three to
five years into the future.
You get to have what you need.
If you're taking care of yourself,
you can have it,
but you have to figure out what it is
because you are not going to get it unless
you aim at it.
And that's rule 10 is be
precise in your speech.
And the reason I wrote that rule is,
is because you can be bloody sure that
you're not going to hit a target unless
you ain't mad it.
And the more precise you make the target,
the higher the probability
that you'll aim at it,
that you'll hit it when you aim at it.
So what do you want?
And you think,
well,
I didn't want to even think about what
I want because as soon as I figured out
what I want,
then I've made clear Mike conditions
for failure and it's the last thing I'm
going to do.
And so people envelop themselves in Vegas
so they don't have to confront their
own failure,
but then they fail and just
don't notice except for maybe,
you know,
two decades when it's too bloody late
and then they're all catastrophic.
Lee hurt because they wasted their life.
It's a very bad plan.
It's better just to figure out what you
want and to tell yourself and then to
tell your partner and to
tell the people around you.
And maybe you can get it or maybe at
least while you're struggling towards it,
you'll come up with a better plan,
which is more likely the case.
What do you want from your family?
If you could have what you,
what was good for you,
what do you want from your
intimate relationship?
How are you going to educate yourself
because you don't know enough?
What do you want for a career or job
because not everyone has a career.
How are you going to spend your time
outside of work in a productive and
meaningful manner?
How are you going to resist
the temptations of drugs
and alcohol and and and
sexual misconduct?
Let's say,
cause those are the big three.
Um,
how are you going to maintain
yourself physically and mentally?
While those are seven good questions,
you can have what you want.
What do you want?
It's an operational realization
of the new testament principle.
Ask and you will receive knock and
the door will open and you think,
well,
no,
there's no possibility
that that's the case.
It's like actually it is the case.
If you don't specify what you want,
you won't get it,
and if you specify what
you want and you want it,
which means you're willing to make
the sacrifices necessary to get it,
then the probability that you'll get it
expands immensely and miraculously in
some sense.
Now,
of course,
it assumes that what you want is within
the bounds of appropriate reason,
let's say,
but you could also dream big and there's
always the possibility that'll work out
too.
So people as answer those questions,
then they write for 15 minutes,
okay,
your life is the way you
want it to be in four years.
What does it look like?
Okay,
right.
As much as you can,
don't worry about being too accurate.
Don't worry about grammar,
spelling.
Don't worry about getting it right
because you're not going to get it right
anyways,
just sketch the damn thing out.
If you could have what you wanted,
what would it be?
And then we have them do the opposite,
which is,
all right,
take stock of yourself for a minute with
all your weaknesses and inadequacies
and bitterness and resentment
and sinful tendencies.
Let's say.
Now imagine that you let all of that goal
and occupy you just wear which little
corner of Hell would you
occupy in three to five years.
Why don't you write about that?
And everyone knows where they
go if they let themselves.
And so then you have something to avoid
and you have something to strive for and
that makes you optimally motivated
because maybe you're afraid,
you know,
you find out you don't like your job
and you're afraid to change your job and
then you think,
oh,
well if I don't change my job,
then I'm heading for this little
corner of Hell that I outlined.
Think,
well that's not a very good plan.
It's very strict,
threatening and stressful
to change my job,
but it beats the hell
out of ending up there.
And so then you have your anxieties behind
you pushing you forward instead of in
front of you,
stopping you called.
And then we asked people to write a
plan to implement their positive vision,
to justify it,
to come up with this strategy for,
for making it into a
real world realization.
And we tested that on thousands
of university students.
Now,
and the upshot was that it decreased the
probability that they would drop out of
university by 30% in fact,
in Canada,
we,
we did it for 90 minutes before
kids went to college in the fall.
They came to their summer orientation,
neither wrote for 90 minutes about
something that required writing,
but there wasn't so relevant or they
wrote out of plan and it dropped the
dropout rate among young men 50% in the
first semester and it had the biggest
effect on young men who didn't do that
well in high school and who weren't
oriented towards a professional career.
The consequence of that was that the
university used it for one year and then
stop doing it.
So,
which was not surprising in the least,
but the reason that I'm laying out this
long story for you is because that's
what people need.
They need,
they need a differentiated
and delineated purpose.
It's way more important than the money.
Okay?
It isn't money that you need.
I know you need money for God's sake.
I'm not ignorant.
Everybody needs money.
That's not the point here.
It's the provision of money
without purpose is not helpful.
And what people need is a purpose and
they need that to develop that for
themselves,
obviously because it's something
you have to participate in,
but it's something that society has to
foster and the reason they need that
purpose is because that's
what gives their life meaning.
Think,
well,
think about this.
Do you really think that you would
be satisfied if you had money without
responsibility?
So what?
Okay,
got no responsibility because
that's what everyone wants.
It's like I had a client,
he wanted to retire when
he was kind of young,
and I said,
well,
what's your retirement dream?
He said,
well,
I envisioned myself on a
beach in a tropical island
with a Margarita in my hand.
And I thought,
what the hell is that?
It's like,
okay,
let's play that out.
Let's be adult about this.
Okay,
so you go down to the,
you're this like red headed white guy.
You go down to the Caribbean and you
sit on a beach and you're sitting in the
beach and you have like six Margaritas
and you're there for like three hours.
What happens the next day?
Okay,
your Sun burnt to a crisp,
right?
So you can't even go out of your
hotel room and you're hung over.
Okay.
And let's say now you hide in your hotel
room for three or four days and you
recover and then you repeat
that every day for three months.
It's like you go outside
and all the locals get away
from you because you're the
new drunk Letcher who's come down from
the north and that's your vision for
retirement.
It's like,
okay,
so you have all the money.
You want no responsibility.
You don't have to take care of yourself.
You don't have a partner,
so you don't have to take care of them.
You don't have any,
you don't have to take care of them.
You don't have a job.
It's like,
what are you going to do?
What are you going to do exactly?
Sit in the sun and Drink Margaritas.
It's like there's no,
no,
that's not a good vision.
You don't want no responsibility.
It's wrong.
People find the meaning in their
life by adopting responsibility.
And so
provision of money,
you know,
they say,
man does not live by bread alone.
And there's wisdom in that.
It's like you don't
want no responsibility.
You might dream about that if
you're crushed by your job,
but then you have the wrong job.
Or do you have the wrong attitude or
you have the wrong job and the wrong
attitude.
I don't know what it is.
You want lots of responsibility
and society needs to
foster that and we need to
help people find their purpose
and their place and that's,
that's more to the point
then universal income,
it's the wrong solution.
[inaudible].